this is really just kind of funny it's a
comedy of errors
ronnie jackson who is now a republican
congressman from texas used to be
trump's lawyer he's the i'm sorry
trump's doctor he's the doctor who
claimed that trump is six feet three
inches tall and weighs 239 pounds
neither is believable look at pictures
of trump next to obama or tom brady and
you'll very quickly realize that
that doctor ronnie jackson went on fox
news and he went back to
i don't even know that this uh evidence
was really there i'm not even sure kind
of alluding again to the fbi planted the
evidence now the problem is they've
already moved many steps beyond that
deflection ronnie i guess not getting
the memo no one trusts the fbi or the
doj anymore i don't trust them any
further that i can throw that entire
building and so this is just their
attempt to try to stave off the special
master who knows what they got out of
there i don't trust these people at all
they came in they spent nine hours in
there they walked in with backpacks they
kicked out uh the president's lawyers
the secret service agents who knows in
my opinion i'm just gonna say if they
told me that they found something i
wouldn't know that they actually found
it there or if they just said they found
it there i don't trust this organization
anymore the american people don't it may
all be planted and of course the problem
is that donald trump and others already
moved on and they went to well the stuff
was there but it was trump's right to
have it or the stuff was there but trump
declassified it or it was whatever
they moved on from this talking point
weeks ago and ronnie jackson seems to be
very very far behind on that at this
point in time he he's often a couple
weeks behind and again when you remember
he told us trump weighs 239 in a 6-3
not a particularly believable guy